the sizzling style at the london
premiere of house of gucci a whimsical
lady gaga work in that purple tool and
mixing it with fishnet stockings gloves
and platform boots salma hayek shining
bright in gold lemay and jared leto
crushing it literally in blue velvet his
accessories diamonds from the necklace
to his human-heart-shaped clutch but
high fashion statements aren't the only
reason to watch this movie there's also
this
[Music]
father son and house of gucci are you
aware how wonderfully quotable this
movie already is in vegas i'll be like
in the middle of a really serious song
and someone will go father
that was just something jared and i did
together so that moment was improvised
father son has a good yeah was it in the
script i don't consider myself a
particularly ethical person no but i am
fair
from that accent to the 80s high fashion
gaga got super deep into character to
play lady gucci patrizia reggiani in
house of gucci out november 24th the
real-life italian socialite was
convicted of arranging the murder of her
husband maurizio played by adam driver
salma hayek is gaga's partner in crime
don't
miss i mean you are all doing these
incredible accents being these
characters for months and months in
italy i gotta say i hadn't seen gaga for
a while unless i heard her yesterday and
i was like oh she sounds so american
it was shocking to me
i really got lost in that character i
find i never have a problem leaving it
alone i always want it to be over i'm
very struck sitting by there's a lot of
star power and talent in front of me
right now when you all came to set who
were you star struck by or really
excited to meet it's al of course
[Laughter]
one of the greatest actors to ever be on
the screen and this is this is a person
who's taught us to reach as high as we
can
to fail often and you know a person who
really changed my life
[Music]